hey leute was geht ab ich wünsche euch
ein frohes neues jahr 2019
ich hoffe er wird ein paar ruhige und
entspannte feiertage und seit gut ins
neue jahr gerutscht
letztes jahr ist eine menge passiert ich
habe mir mal einige rückblicke
angeschaut und klar sind da viele
wichtige dinge dabei politische
ereignisse unglücke sport unterhaltung
aber mir ist auch aufgefallen dass große
ereignisse der wissenschaft kaum
auftritte in vielen jahresrückblicken
hatten
ich denke das liegt daran dass
wissenschaft oft nicht so spektakulär an
nicht so greifbar ist wie die täglichen
ereignisse einer wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnis gehen oft monate oder sogar
jahre harte arbeit voraus und es folgen
nach der ankündigung noch weitere jahre
harte arbeit
die ergebnisse müssen überprüft
experimente wiederholt werden und selbst
dann dauert es oft noch jahre oder sogar
jahrzehnte bis ein durchbruch auch
wirklich die leben der menschen
verändert wenn es dann so weit ist dann
ist die news schon lange alt dabei sorgt
aber gerade die wissenschaft für die
größten veränderungen viel mehr als der
aktuelle promi klatsch
deswegen habe ich mal zehn andere
wissens youtuber eingeladen zusammen mit
mir die wichtigsten ereignisse der
wissenschaft 2018 zusammenzufassen was
war unserer meinung nach wichtig was ist
es wert gefeiert oder betraut zu werden
ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß dabei
und falls ihr die youtuber die jetzt
kommen noch nicht kennt dann schaut auch
gerne mal auf den jeweiligen kanälen
vorbei alle machen tolle arbeit ich habe
jeden einzelnen kanal unten in der video
beschreibung verlinkt
[Musik]
2018 ist in der wissenschaft hier
passiert das beeindruckendste ereignis
für mich war aber die erfolgreiche
quantenkommunikation mit mehr als zwei
teilnehmern
denn die rechenleistung von
quantencomputern wächst dank seiner
cubes exponentiell zur bittlinger
klassische verschlüsselung werden so in
minuten wird klagt deswegen setzt man
auch quanten verschlüsselung aber das
hat bisher nur für zwei teilnehmer
geklappt 2018 haben forscher der
universität wien eine netzwerk
architektur entwickelt die eine
kommunikation mehrerer teilnehmer
zugleich ermöglicht dafür eine photon
quelle drei photon paare erzeugt die
eine unbekannte aber jeweils identische
ausrichtung des lichts hatten vier
teilnehmer bekamen jeweils drei dieser
sechs lichtteilchen und trotz der immer
zufälligen messergebnisse bekam sie
immer gleiche ergebnisse bei den photon
power und konnten so die schlüssel für
die verschlüsselung erzeugen
damit ist gezeigt dass quante netzwerke
realität werden können
der erste schritt zum quanten internet
web.de
das ist wirklich 2018 eingeschlagen wie
eine bombe da kommt ein astrophysiker
aus harvard und zwar nicht irgendeiner
sondern der leiter des bereichs
astronomie und sagt das interstellare
objekte humor das im september 2017
durch unser sonnensystem gerast ist
könnte eine alien sonne gewesen sein
professor abramov in einem
exklusivinterview bei pixum science
fiction
ich würde es als eine realistische
möglichkeit neben einen natürlichen
ursprung betrachten
sein hauptargument das objekt wurde so
stark von der sonne beschleunigt dass es
laut seinen berechnungen ein sehr
leichtes licht segel gewesen sein muss
dicke 0,3 bis 0,9 mm hammer
haye ist jakob vom kanal breaking mein
lieblings moment im jahr 2018 war wohl
als der curiosity rover bilder von
organischen material zur erde geschickt
hat jeder hat natürlich sofort an leben
auf dem mars gedacht es gab verschiedene
- die durchs internet gegeistert sind
und unzählige zeitungsartikel wo
teilweise drin spekuliert wurde ob es
jetzt aliens gibt und natürlich ist das
alles total übertrieben organisches
material hat eigentlich nur das ein
material aus kohlenstoff und in den
meisten fällen aus wasserstoff besteht
und in einigen fällen noch aus
sauerstoff oder stickstoff oder anderen
elementen und auch wenn organische
moleküle meisten mit leben in verbindung
gebracht werden so können sie auch durch
nicht biologische prozesse entstehen und
somit ist das ganze eigentlich kein
richtiger beweis für ein leben aber die
nachricht ist trotzdem spektakulär
kombiniert man das mit dem wissen über
wasser auf dem mars ist es plötzlich gar
nicht mehr so unwahrscheinlich dass es
dort mein leben gegeben und cool es auch
dass wir schon im nächsten jahr mehr
aufschluss darüber haben werden denn
dann kommt ein neuer master und es kommt
ein extra so war der esa auf dem mars an
und diese mit speziellem equipment
ausgestattet was darauf spezialisiert
ist leben festzustellen und wer weiß was
die herausfinden werden es bleibt auf
jeden fall spannend hey meine
neugierigen freunde hier spricht markus
vom kanal neugier zone main bregenz dass
wissenschaftliches ereignis im jahr 2018
war der erfolgreiche jungfernflug der
space ex rakete falcon heavy am 6
februar space ex ist ein privates
raumfahrtunternehmen gegründet von elon
musk der meiner meinung nach größten
visionär der letzten jahrhunderte
noch nie hat ein mensch science fiction
und realität so nah aneinander gebracht
der jungfernflug der falcon heavy war
ein meilenstein auf elon musk weg zum
mars die busse der rakete sollen wieder
verwendbar sein
und tatsächlich schafften es zwei der
drei bussen wieder sicher auf der erde
zu landen
die landung schaut fast schon unwirklich
aus das ziel des jungfernflugs war es
zunächst ein ob diese rakete ein
massives objekt in eine umlaufbahn um
die sonne bringen kann als testobjekt
wählte elon musk einen tesla roadster
aus seinem eigenen besitz und die
mission war erfolgreich
der tesla schwebt seitdem im weltall
mehr ja ich weiss es gab 2008 sind jede
menge große sensationen in der
wissenschaft große funde entdeckungen
und vieles mehr
einiges ist ja auch schon angeklungen in
diesem video aber ich würde gerne über
eine sache sprechen die gar nicht so
groß in den medien war die mich aber
trotzdem sehr beschäftigt hat 2018
durften französische wissenschaftler zum
ersten mal das gebiss adolf hitlers
untersuchen und dabei kam heraus ja es
ist tatsächlich das gebiss hitlers warum
ist das so wichtig naja bis 1 gab es
immer wieder legenden und mythen die
besagt haben hitler wäre zum beispiel
nach argentinien geflohen hätte dort
noch lange gelebt hat die kinder
bekommen der führer würde weiterleben
das haben die jungs immer wieder gesagt
und jetzt ist klar nein so ist es nicht
hitler ist 1945 ums leben gekommen er
sich das leben selber genommen mit
zyankali hat sich auch noch in den kopf
geschossen
es war ja niemand dabei aus der eva
braun die auch um gekommen ist und jetzt
weiß man das eben ganz sicher das ist
gut denn diese ganzen legenden die es da
gab die haben vor allem neonazis genutzt
und die kameras ganz klar als lüge
bezeichnet würde ich eine positive sache
2018 hat uns einer der größten physiker
aller zeiten verlassen stephen hawking
bis kurz vor seinem tod hat er noch an
der antwort auf eine große frage
gearbeitet
was passiert mit informationen in einem
schwarzen loch materie oder licht
strahlung die an schwarzen loch zu nahe
kommen werden unausweichlich aufgesogen
und können diese umgebung nie mehr
verlassen
das heißt informationen geht in einem
schwarzen loch verloren
und genau das ist ein widerspruch denn
nach den gesetzen der quantenmechanik
kann keine informationen aus dem
universum einfach so gelöscht werden
also auf quantenebene
in seiner letzten wissenschaftlichen
arbeit hat stephen hawking mit seinen
kollegen gezeigt wie zumindest ein teil
der informationen die in ein schwarzes
loch stürzt erhalten bleiben kann wenn
ein teilchen in ein schwarzes loch fällt
ändert es unter anderem dessen entropie
das ist ein maß für die unordnung und
diese entropie wird von photonen
aufgezeichnet die gerade am
ereignishorizont des schwarzen lochs
sitzen diese photonen nennen hawking und
co weiche haare und das ist vielleicht
ein wichtiger schritt um dieses
informations paradox zu lösen und das
universum ein kleines bisschen besser zu
verstehen dass für mich wichtigste
ereignis der wissenschaft 2018 war die
erfolgreiche inside london
die nasa-sonde setzte ihren ländern nach
über sechs monaten flug am 26 november
in der elysium planitzer auf dem mars ab
der länder vermeldet am tag darauf dass
die systeme ordnungsgemäß arbeiteten und
die sonnenkollektoren wie geplant
ausgefahren wurden gleichzeitig schickte
insight ein beeindruckendes bild seiner
neuen heimat an die erde
der stationäre länder der erstmals in
der nasa geschichte ausschließt nicht
mit europäischen auch deutschen
instrumenten bestückt ist wird in den
kommenden zwei jahren seismische und
thermische untersuchungen der maß kostet
durchführen ziel der mission ist die
gewinnung grundlegende erkenntnisse über
den aufbau und die entstehung des mars
denn gerade mit hinblick auf die
formierung terrestrischer planeten hat
die planetologie hier immer noch große
verständnis lücken der 26 november ist
in mehrfacher hinsicht ein highlight des
jahres 2018
zum einen ist jede erfolgreiche landung
auf dem roten planeten einen meilen
stand zusätzlich kam es im rahmen der
insight mission zu einer premiere zwei
mini satelliten namens mars cubes a und
b folgten der sonne und übermittelten
die daten ihrer landung
es ist zwar bereits der 42 stupid los
aber die aktentaschen großen mini
satelliten kam zum ersten mal auf einer
interplanetaren mission zum einsatz
und sie haben ihre familie mit bravour
gemeistert inside war damit in vielerlei
hinsicht eine bahnbrechende mission für
die nasa die raumfahrt sowie die
wissenschaft allgemein und in diesem
sinne 42
eines der spannendsten ereignisse 2018
war für mich der start des
weltraumteleskops tests das im april von
der nase in den erdorbit geschossen
wurde und um die 200.000 verschiedene
sterne nach extrasolaren planeten
untersuchen soll
aktuell können wir etwa um die 4000
planeten außerhalb unseres sonnensystems
die von den verschiedensten teleskopen
bisher bestätigt wurden und 70 prozent
aller bekannten extrasolaren planeten
sind erst in den letzten drei bis vier
jahren gefunden worden
das heißt wir haben jetzt mit der suche
ist wirklich angefangen und tests sollen
und dafür sorgen dass diesen zahlen noch
einmal einen deutlichen push gegeben
wird vor allem da ist das erste
weltraumteleskop ist das nicht auf einem
bereich in der milchstraße begrenzt ist
sondern eine karte von 85 prozent des
nachthimmels erstellen wird was wirklich
interessant machen wir zu sehen was wir
vom test in den kommenden jahren alles
mitbekommen werden für mich war ein
highlight im jahr 2018 im bereich
astronomie im moment ist da ja sehr viel
bewegung drin also sehr viele missionen
die zum mond oder zum mars gestartet
werden
aber letztes jahr hat eine mission einen
meilenstein erreicht die vor 40 jahren
gestartet ist im jahr 1977 ist die
voyager 2 von der erde aus gestartet und
hat am 5 november 2008 10 den
interstellaren raum betreten heißt also
im prinzip wie wolter 2 ist außerhalb
unseres sonnensystems
denn nach definition endet das
sonnensystem dort wo die sonnenwinde die
sich kugelförmig um die sonne ausbreiten
zum stillstand kommen also im
gleichgewicht sind mit dem
interstellaren raum und das definiert
dann die grenze und die beute zwei hat
diesen raum verlassen
die leute zwei ist also so weit entfernt
von der erde das kein partikel und
teilchen von der sonne die leute zwei
jemals mehr erreichen kann und trotz
alledem empfangen wir alle daten die die
beute zwei doch zur erde
dieses jahr also und bis dezember um
genau zu sein
mit alexander gerst mal die da einen
deutschen auf der hss und dieses mal
dann auch den ersten deutschen
kommandanten und er hat da oben ziemlich
werk voller experimente gemacht und so
sehr ich auch experimenten feiere muss
ich sagen dass das wertvollste was er da
oben so für mich gemacht hat seine
twitter aktivität war
klingt vielleicht ein bisschen komisch
aber als wissens youtuber weiß ich wie
wichtig es ist leute themen zu
interessieren sich bild der meinung dass
immer zwei aktivität und den ganzen
tollen bildern wie er geteilt hat den
fokus vieler lächeln wie auch die
raumfahrt geweckt hat und somit auch die
wissenschaft er hat gezeigt wie
faszinierend zeigen es doch sein kann
und das kann eine menge leute dazu
inspirieren oder wissenschaft zu wecken
vielen dank an alle wissens youtuber die
mitgemacht haben wie gesagt findet ihr
unten die ganzen links zu den jeweiligen
kanälen nun aber noch zu den meiner
meinung nach wichtigsten ereignissen in
der wissenschaft im letzten jahr ein
junger chinesischer forscher hat ende
des jahres bekannt gegeben dass er die
relativ neue gehen manipulations methode
chris benutzt hat um ein bestimmtes gen
zu modifizieren
das ist an und für sich noch nichts
neues allerdings hat er dies an eizellen
gemacht die nun zu kindern geboren
wurden
die veränderung sorgt dafür dass die
kinder lebenslagen vor einer hiv
infektion geschützt sind und diese
eigenschaft auch an nachkommende
generationen weitergeben
damit haben wir menschen eine wichtige
grenze übertreten
wir haben unser eigenes erbgut verändert
viele forscher und auch bekannte
persönlichkeiten warnen vor den
möglichen gefahren von gm editing es
könnte die ungleichheit auf der welt
verstärken und gesundheitliche folgen
haben die wir jetzt noch gar nicht
absehen können wie entwickelt sich eine
einzelne zelle zu einem komplexen
lebewesen
diese frage stellen wir uns schon seit
tausenden von jahren und nun haben wir
endlich alle nötigen werkzeuge um sie zu
beantworten
durch das isolieren markieren und
sequenzieren von zellen können
wissenschaftler nun in unglaublicher
detailtiefe beobachten wie sich zellen
vermehren und wann welche zellen aktiv
werden 2018 konnten zehn bisher
ungeklärte fälle mit einer neuen methode
gelöst werden
die ermittler fanden dns der täter am
tatort und glichen diese mit einer
öffentlichen dns datenbank ab dabei
suchten sie nach menschen die ähnliches
erbgut besitzen und vielleicht mit den
eigentlichen tätern verwandt sind
auf diese weise wurde zum beispiel ein
serienmörder gefangen genommen der seine
taten vor über 30 jahren begangen hat in
der zukunft wird diese methode
wahrscheinlich noch häufiger benutzt um
kriminelle zur strecke zu bringen
was ist eurer meinung nach 2018 das
wichtigste ereignis in der wissenschaft
gewesen war es eines von denen die wir
genannt haben oder gab es vielleicht
doch was ganz anderes dass wir
vielleicht vergessen haben schreibt es
mir gerne unten in die kommentare
ich freue mich schon sehr darauf mit
euch zu diskutieren nochmals vielen dank
an alle youtube an die mitgemacht haben
danke an meine pages of passion die
dieses video möglich gemacht haben und
wie immer bleibt neugierig
[Musik]